make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into Marvel
Zombies resurrection here's the thing
though
recently Marvel renamed it from respawn
to resurrection I don't know where this
takes place app like I don't know if it
takes place in the main Marvel Universe
I don't know if it takes place in like
an alternate reality and I've googled
all over the place and I can find no
indication of where this story takes
place as best as I can tell us a reboot
basically of like the the whole Marvel
Zombies concept but I don't I don't know
where that I mean I have a hard time
believing it takes place like in
continuity in Marvel but I could be
wrong maybe somebody has found something
that I haven't but I haven't been able
to find anything that indicates that's
the case instead what we end up doing
here is basically picking up at the
headquarters of the Fantastic Four and
the reason why and this is why these are
kind of interesting here is because
what's happened is Reed Richards has
basically called together the Illuminati
but notice this Stephen strange isn't
here right so that's kind of an
indication that it does not take place
in the main Marvel Universe although we
don't know really explicitly but
regardless the the way this kind of goes
down is is Reed Richards basically tells
all these guys who were here that what
ended up happening is they essentially
that they he basically picked up a
deep-space message from Carol Danvers
who basically sent an SOS right she's
like everything's going crazy and like
there's something here but but the whole
message was kind of garbled and sort of
broken up and it was impossible to tell
exactly what it was as she was
referencing but all Reed Richards got
was basically this image that Galactus
is out in space and that Galactus
appears to be dead now when this happens
all the members of the Illuminati almost
begin to panic and rightfully so right
like we've only seen a couple instances
where Galactus has died like for example
there was one instance where Galactus
died and then we got Abraxas kind of
this representation of the multiverses
destruction he was super powerful entity
that basically jumped from one universe
to the next killing every version of
Galactus that he found right we did a
video on it and you'll find that video
down in the description up but there's
there's different things that kind of
come out of it but the big thing about
this is the amount of power it would
take for a being to successfully kill
Galactus is is astronomical right it
would have to be something equal to him
meaning like Celestials or something
like that or greater but because of the
fact that Galactus is a cosmic entity
meaning that he serves particular
purpose and no celestial or a really
cosmic entity out there would kill
Galactus because he's an essential force
in the universe what this means is it
was a non cosmic entity that basically
killed him and that's why they're kind
of panicking here that's why they're
kind of freaking out is because but what
they're come to the realization of is
that some being out there this humanoid
in nature whether there's an alien or
whatever the case
was powerful enough to destroy the
lactis and that really begged the
attention of everybody more so than that
the big concern is that because of
Galactus were so capable because he's so
old because his power is so vast and
because those individuals who can
harness his ability will in turn gain
access to the power cosmic to say
nothing of the technology that he has on
his ship they basically panic I said we
got to get out there and basically get
as much stuff as we can before anybody
else gets their hands on it now it's
interesting because it's easy to look at
that from like a villainous perspective
right like all right guys Galactus
apparently he's dead okay let's go just
like plunder his corpse let's go plunder
his remains before anybody else does
because we don't want to be left with
the leftovers we want to get the good
stuff up but that's not really the case
it's one of these things where there's a
lot of different enemies out there as
one of the things that it's easy to
forget and Marvel Comics there's a lot
of races out there that would love to
destroy humanity or conquer the universe
and using the power of Galactus they
could conceivably do that right and so
because that what ends up happening is
by virtue of Beast and Captain America
as well as Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four the x-men the The
Avengers and the Fantastic Four come
together as a singular team now this is
not the full contingent of the x-men and
is certainly not the full contingent of
the Avengers right there's like four
Avengers who were here there's a
smattering of x-men who are here but
it's basically a pretty heavy hitting
team right I mean you got neato you've
got Iron Man you guys are pretty heavy
hitters really and you know here people
who are basically able to to put some
significant punches you have four
different things like that and so the
results of this is that as they begin to
get closer and closer to the location
what they end up doing is is basically
realizing that Galactus is actually dead
or it was kind of believed that maybe
he's alive or maybe he's just kind of
unconscious or he was heading to earth
or whatever the case is given the
trajectory the indication is that he was
heading towards Earth and for whatever
reason he stopped once they get here
they realize Galactus is definitively
dead right Galactus is basically out of
the picture here and so following this
it really turns into kind of a
reconnaissance mission is really what it
turns into right let's get in here let's
see what's going on let's see what it
was that killed him and let's kind of
let's figure things out and go from
there now of course
Wolverine being here is one of the first
people to basically realize that there's
somebody else there but they don't
really know the full extent of it right
it's just kind of like okay something
seems a little off here the reality is
that the overall situation seems a
little off right the whole thing seems a
little murky but at the end of the day
it really is reading them trying to
solve this mystery and trying to figure
out what's going on and so as a result
of that as time begins to pass what is
happening is their groups are basically
split into sections right Reed Richards
and his guys basically stay behind they
kind of track down what's going on with
Galactus and all that kind of stuff
Iron Man of course stays there and a
couple other people in the firm there
you have the x-men which is basically
Wolverine and and magic and maybe one or
two other people who go and investigate
and then you have the Avengers who go in
and investigate as well right so right
it's kind of splitting up into groups
and going to see what's going on the
problem with this is that once they get
out there they're basically met by
somebody
Wolverine begins to panic and everybody
else just seems to kind of be like what
the heck is going on and so what they
end up doing is realizing that what
happened with Galactus at least what
seems to be going on here is that
Galactus has in effect been hollowed out
that what's taking place here is
somebody somewhere killed Galactus and
then basically hollowed him out in such
a way and began to channel his energy
throughout his body so that it could be
used as basically kind of like a
makeshift ship now that's not the first
time that we've seen that and it's one
of the cool things about how this gets
done right those are guys to remember
the Thanos imperative story for example
we had the cancerverse and inside that
universe Galactus had basically been
been destroyed and what this led to was
the creation of what was called the
Galactus engine right this massive
engine of destruction so we've seen
stories where Galactus has been defeated
in some form or fashion and then
repurposed by various people and then
used for a particular cause so it's not
the first time we've seen something like
this and it's actually pretty
interesting but what we end up realizing
is this mystery person that the x-men
and the Avengers were talking to you
was none other than Carol Danvers
herself and this is important and the
reason why is because what we end up
learning is that this was that that the
distress signal that was sent out to
Reed Richards was sent by the zombified
version of Carol the other thing that
goes on here and this is kind of crazy
about this is what what sort of throws
me off is Wolverine makes reference to
remembering her now in terms of him
saying like I remember Hugh it's not
like I remember you you're Carol Danvers
as that's not what he's referencing it's
I remember you use obby type person you
and that's why I say it kind of throws
me off on where this takes place right
because at the end of Marvel Zombies
return when they were when they were in
Earth's Z spider-man basically tried to
find a cure for the zombie plague and
then took took Wolverines body with him
and then I don't think we ever found out
what happened to it and so it's entirely
possible that this takes place and like
an alternate universe or something along
those lines where Wolverine was taken by
spider-man who was cured and then dumped
here maybe we don't really know exactly
what it is that's going on we don't know
how these zombies got here I mean it is
only the first issue so there's probably
a lot of explanation and a lot of
extrapolation coming out of it
the issue with this is that Wolverine
basically panics right so the fact that
he knows who Carol Danvers is and he
recognizes this zombie concept basically
tells him to tell he tells everybody get
out of here everybody run get out of
here as fast as you possibly can
and of course Wolverine is set upon by
these these by the Shiar the scrolls the
whole nine yards that what we were what
we're really looking at here and what
seems to be the case is that whatever
place these zombies hail from they're
all inside Galactus right they all use
Galactus his body to get here now it
could be it was used as a it's kind of a
dimensional jump right and we've seen
that before too that's one of the cool
things about this is Galactus had been
used for a lot of purposes those he got
to work at who-who don't know what I'm
talking about
during Jonathan Hickman's run on the
Fantastic Four what he did is there was
a segment in the story where he
basically gave those gave us the future
of the old man Logan universe and what
ended up happening in that future of old
man Logan which I don't think is really
in continuity anymore but what ended up
happening in that future is ultimately
ah earth was kind of liberated for lack
of a better word by all the various
villains who had risen up and and taking
control of everything and so Hulk jr.
the the baby version of The Incredible
Hulk that old man had old man Logan had
rescued at the end of the story
basically grew up to have his own
superhero team the issue with that is
Earth was essentially coming to a close
it was basically going to be destroyed
and so when Galactus arrived to consume
it ultimately Galactus was defeated and
then his body was used as a means to
essentially jump out of that dimension
and into the main Marvel Universe so
we've seen that happen before right it's
not uncommon to see that I mean it's
kind of like common leave only scene at
once but it's not unheard of so that's
one of the cool things these aren't
really just being yanked out of nowhere
we've seen this kind of stuff happen
before and so what they end up doing is
basically tracing this kind of main
source of energy the brain so to speak
of how all this stuff works
down to this kind of weird pit of sorts
only for Norrin Radd for the Silver
Surfer to emerge and then basically say
like come MC right like come and join us
and this is something that we haven't
really seen from the Marvel Zombies
right as with the muffled zombies it was
we have to spread the gospel that's what
the Marvel Zombies always said we never
really saw them say come and see or
never really heard them say come and see
and so this is cool this is interesting
is a wholly new take it looks like on
the entire Marvel Zombies mythos but the
overall gist of this is this is when the
dime starts and the first one to fall is
Johnny Storm after that all hell begins
to break loose magic is consumed by the
zombies who in turn along with a whole
bunch of other people end up attacking
Magneto and so magneto falls the cool
thing of
this is a Captain America it's only a
matter of time before he falls right
and he actually directs Thor to get out
to get out of there as fast as he can
but to basically go back to - James
Rhodes who's been stowing away or been
sitting on the ship in case things pop
off and then fly it back to earth now
Thor of course being the warrior that we
know he is is not readily willing to
just leave his friends behind right like
you got a cap and then just bail that's
not really what Thor does Thor wants to
fight in to the bitter end we would
expect nothing less of his character but
at the end of the day he's directed by
Captain America and this is the kind of
respect that Captain America commands
within the superhero universe right but
it's like get out of here go back to
earth if you fall the whole world will
fall and so as a result of that Thor
ends up coming face-to-face with a
gladiator and this is a fight that I
don't think we've ever really seen right
like like in the modern era a
bare-knuckle brawl between Thor and
gladiator the downside of this is that
we don't see it we never get to see that
take place instead Johnny Storm
basically falls Susan storm isn't trying
to rescue him as best she can it doesn't
work ah Ben Grimm ends up taking out
Johnny Storm and then everything
continues to kind of run amuck
everything begins to panic only for for
a Susan storm to in turn become a zombie
herself try to stop Reed Richards and
then it seems as though Reed Richards
basically gets turned right like Reed
Richards ends up becoming a zombie
himself and so as a result of that when
James rose is sitting on the ship and
he's like okay so what's going on Thor
comes flying now he believes it's helped
only for us to find out it's a zombified
Thor and then in turn like they just go
they go heading back to earth inside
Galactus right like in the span of
minutes and that's the thing to
understand here this wasn't a battle
that took place over the course of a day
in a matter of minutes all the
superheroes that were there all of them
fall just like that and it's kind of a
sight to behold it's kind of amazing to
see that right because ultimately what
ends up happening is is where you end up
having a Peter Parker basically talking
to two valaria Richards and so on and
then supposedly Franklin Richards around
there somewhere Galactus basically comes
crashing down to earth and this is kind
of the cool thing here because here's my
question here's my real big question
here when all of the Marvel Zombies show
up on the on earth in the main Marvel
Universe can Franklin Richards stop them
and if Franklin Richards cannot stop
them what happens if Franklin Richards
becomes one of them without being said
guys we're gonna bleed this video to an
end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
you